in a time of social division we often
hear about how politics drives us apart
but we never really hear about what
brings us together well it turns out
some pretty simple things can help like
living in a community rich in amenities
such as grocery stores parks libraries
bars and restaurants even gyms a recent
AEI survey finds that people who live
within a walking distance or a short
drive from a grocery store park or
favorite restaurant know their neighbors
better than people who live farther out
people who live close to their favorite
bar or restaurant gym or theater are
much more likely to rate their community
an excellent place to live than people
who have to drive more than 15 minutes
57% of people who walk to their grocery
store talk to their neighbors several
times a week compared to just 42% of
those who have to drive more than 15
minutes now it may not be a panacea but
where we live and how we design our
communities might just be a good first
step toward hating each other less and
maybe learning to get along a little bit
more what about your community do you
like most let us know in your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI